[Applause]
all right well we have her we have 50
said here we do this every time we show
you two items that are similar one is
more expensive than the other and you
have to guess which one is thriftier and
you you've almost never been wrong if
you've been watching uh 50 has correctly
guessed seven out of eight times
throughout history okay and these are
tough let's see if the streak continues
with is 50 50.
okay now before we play I I actually
have to ask you about this because I
found out you actually like to go
thrifting like you go to thrift stores
when you travel I'll go well I like to
look at things and I go oh ain't no way
I'm paying that much for that
even when it's high-end stuff I look and
say
you know sometimes the shirt be eight
dollars and they want eighty dollars for
it because it got fashion they wanted
uh-huh and I look at it like no that's
the Eight dollar shirt bro all right
well then let's play we have someone
here to help us showcase each item
straight from the set of the prices
right it's Devin godox
thank you
hi buddy good to see you again good to
see you thank you for being here
thanks for coming all right you excited
to help us play oh I can't wait I can't
wait all right well here's what we're
gonna do we're going to try to stump 50.
first up we have these fluffy rugs yeah
it is all right so uh which 150 is
Thrifty
it looked nice
I love how you get into it let me see I
got to make sure you know walk me
through what you're feeling
yeah this one is more expensive okay why
why do you think because the back of it
the lining in the back is a lot more
this is the thriftier one um
okay this is a hundred and forty dollars
so if the white one is more than 140
dollars you're wrong 50. okay R50 let's
go
oh
you're right
I don't know how he does it all right
let's see if we can keep it up next up
Devin let's show off these beautiful
days yeah this is nice right here I like
how you do this with the hands that's so
good I think that's the more affordable
one this one's the Thrifty why do you
think
I don't know the shiny stuff just feels
like I feel you
it's a little cheesy
[Applause]
all right so let's see if number one
is more expensive let's take a look at
how much that is here we go
139 and you say that's the most the more
expensive one right yeah so let's take a
look at number two
[Applause]
today you are undefeated so it all comes
down 50 to these massage chairs now I
think this is going to be difficult yeah
I think so too all right so what are you
looking for here in your expertise of
massage chairs I just got to feel the
thing I gotta vote ain't no way they're
going to give me you do you want to sit
in it this one is more expensive than
this one this is the cheaper one I don't
know this is nice though wait a minute
wait a minute
wait a minute
the audience is screaming sitting it yes
okay
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what word is coming to mind to describe
that chair I was sleeping on this one
this one definitely cost more okay you
say number two is more expensive so
let's take a look at number one
[Applause]
twenty one hundred dollars
okay how are you feeling before we
reveal the answer how are you feeling
about your choice
I didn't know these chairs was this
expensive
okay if number two is less than twenty
one hundred dollars then 50 you'll be
wrong for the first time today no but
they got the um
okay Tevin let's take a look
we finally stumped 50. wow
[Applause]
because when I first picked I first
picked this one you did and then I went
over there because y'all said oh it was
the wrong one
[Applause]
The Price is Right they do that to
people all the time all the time all the
time
two out of three isn't bad you feeling
okay all right let's hear
[Applause]
make sure you all watch The Price Is
Right on CBS
we'll be right back
[Music]